the boats may look simple but their
design is intricate and complex Towell
boat builders journey deep into the
forest
to find the 11 different species of tree
needed to make a tata lock
centuries of experience go into making
these boats the wood for the keel is
heavy to keep the boat's entered the
woods used for the sides are light and
buoyant to help it float only an axe is
used to shape each part and wooden pegs
hold the whole thing together there
isn't a single nail it's a real work of
art building at Alcala takes around five
months but with good care it can last
more than 10 years to make sure my Tala
survives this journey I need to fix
those cracks and that means heading
inland in search of a rare tree the
interior of the island is so mountainous
that most of the forest is completely
inaccessible even the parts the toe can
reach are a tough climb away
the tree I'm looking for only grows in a
handful of places but the towel always
know where to find such a valuable plant
finally I reach my goal a tree they call
Faruk that's gotta be it
they're hard to find so the elders they
mark these trees so they can find them
again showing how important a tree like
this is to the tell people what's
important about it is in the roots yeah
right there the roots of the Farouk tree
are surrounded by these strange densely
packed fibers it's like cotton fibers
really super soft and lofty just bizarre
stuff in all my travels I've never seen
a tree that makes that kind of stuff
bizarre back at the shore I get to work
on my repairs
I need the hammer the Farook fibers into
the tracks these tiny fibers they act
just like the wood when they get wet
they swell this is the sort of
indigenous technology that have been
keeping people going out here for
centuries
simple but effective it's all about
knowing the resources that are out there
[Music]
really